*DEATH METAL STARTS HELL YEAAAAAAAAAAAH*
*Machiavellian laughter*
It's me
*coughing*
*starts to die*
*his life flashes right before his eyes*
*rip pewds*
Poodiepie: the greatest gamer on YouTube. I have the most subscribers which means I have the most
SKILL!
*Weird accent* Aaah, oh this game is a little hard !
*Weird accent* Aaah, oh this game is so little hard !
Ooooh, booohooo,
*Oh booohooo.
Boeoheohoehhooo
It's just like-a Dark Souls. I asked you to challenge me for real. I ask you "Hey give me a real game,
It's just like a dog. So I asked you to challenge me for real. I asked you :
Give me a real challenge."
"Give me a real challenge"
* high pitched voice* hey pewdiepie you should play i wanna be the guy, its a really hard game, its just like dark souls.
HEADPHONE WARNING!!!!!!
*Loud Megaman music*
Aaaaaaaaaah...
AHHHH *looks at headphones*
Jesus Christ
*Game squeals*
I wanna to be the guy, the movie, the game.
Want to be the guy the movie the game, so you jump with shift what the fuck are these controls ?
So, you jump with "Shift".
What the f*ck are these controls?
I must be able to shoot then. Okay I can.
Okay, okay fine.
OH, The game is hard, they say. OO- *dies the first try*
Whatever zero deaths, let's do that again. HeeeeEEeeyY
WOAH OKAY HERE WE GO
*mocking voice* Oh, The game is so hard. OH.
*mocking voice*The game is so hard. Oh
Oh, wow, look how hard that game was.
Wow, look how hard that game was
Easy trap -- anyone can see through that sh*t.
Get the f*** away from me, trap.
Alright, next level--*failure #3*
Zero deaths!! This is the easiest game I've ever played in my life.
I just have to stand here. Oh, wow.
Oh wow that is Super hard
That is SUPER hard.
That's, like, straight up impossible.
Alright, I wonder what the next one is going to do.
*DISAPPOINTED*
Oh, I gotta run
Oh, wow, this-- OooOH.
What the f*ck was that? Shut up, what the f*ck?
How the hell am I gonna be able to do that?
Ooo, that one touched my nip ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
I like it. Do it again please. Come back!
I love you, I LOVE YOU, please stay with me I wanna-- Oh sh*t.
Missed me b*tch.
This is not hard. This is memorizing a series of patterns, which is child's play anyone can do this.
Anyone. Give me a challenge that requires skill with these magical fingers, okay, give me that
f*ck you
What the f*ck am I doing wrong there?
It just hits me anyway, what the f*ck am I supposed to do?
My God, this is so f*cking boring. I have to wait for this shit every f*cking time.
Oh, wait, I can't swear because the video will get demonetized.
I mean-- no! This is--go!!
GO
Jump over there. You didn't jump!! You mOROn!
Gogogogogogogogogo
You didn't jump what the f*ck is wrong with you?! I get it now
I get it.
I got it before I started.
I just wanted to pretend that I'm bad just so you feel bad about yourself. Just so you feel like oh,
maybe he's not that good. I'm f*cking good. Okay watch this; first time I've ever played this game.
I bet you had to watch tutorials to play this game.
*High-pitched* Oh wow! I beat darksouls on my third try!
Yeah, did you look online people playing it on YouTube
Yeah, did you look online people playing it on YouTube because then it doesn't fucking count YOU didn't jump oh wait
because then it doesn't f*cking count. DIDN'T JUMP....
oh wait, He can double jump... oooooh
*pewdipie discover how to play*
oOH
Oh, i see, you can play with EZ mode.
Fine
Fine, 'cuz i am the guy!
Double jump, more like bitch jump
Alright, look at this
Why it's not coming now?
no skill
how am I supposed to make it all the way?!? how oh my God this game is so dumb to play and be
Absolutely loved that's offensive there every other game in the world
You don't have to think not played a zelda game before they straight up. Oh my God that's so offensive
Go go go go
Hit me
How do I get there?
'right, how do I get there?
I just walk down
I dump what happened to double jumping huh, what happened to double jumping huh does it count as a jump
Did you walk off idiocy this game is STAHPID STAHPID game you stupid
Did you walk off idiocy this game is stupid stupid game you stupid !
I mean it's barely scratch your surfaces
I mean this.. "thing"
oh, I get it. I get it now !
I get it now, lookatme lookatme lookatme
*cue weebanese*
Okay, look and then we go back. Oh
*boring censored content*
This is the first stage
So I'm free to walk here now, but as soon as I hit a certain point... The "thing" activates... there.
So I'm free to walk here now, but as soon as I hit a certain point
*Genius*
How am I supposed to make that jump how how am I suppose to make that
HAW
jumP
*no skill again*
How is that even physically possible? It's way, too...
There must be a way with these, these brown things in the back that must be a way with them. There's some secret to them. Oh
I know I got it. I got it before you got it shush you shush you I got it*alright we get it*
I got it. Okay. I don't need you to tell me oh*high pitched voice* PEWDIEPIE WHAT YOU NEED TO DO
*frustrated people* OH pewdipie, what u need to do is...It's so Obvious. It's so obvious, pewdie
It's so Obvious. It's so obvious PEWDIE
*high-pitched's pewds voice again* OOOOOOOOH
*dying whale noise* OHHHH
No, no, no no no no, look at that
*A genius is born*
*censored content* GENIUS!
SO SMARD! you see that *censored*
So smart you see that shit
*frustrated people* OH I beated... it was really easy !
Okay
Okay, can we move on now easy this game is easy you see how we haven't hit the save yet. OH God
There is gonna be a trap here by the same
*Censored* You not on my *censored content* watch
You not on my fucking  watch
Got it got it. Oh wow these spikes fell down ! Oh, what is this? We're gonna shoot up. Oh
Got it got it. Oh wow this spike fell down. Oh, what is this? We're gonna shoot up. Oh
Wow, oh, what did the apples go into attack me n- *what*
LOL
Oooh wow, let me guess the water makes me survive
You don't die in water great now what the fuck do i do then?
You don't die in water great, now what the *censored content* do I do then ?
*exasperated pewds*
There best not be two apples in that spike if there's two apples in this spike this guy is not gonna be happy
That best not be two apples in that spike if there's two apples in that spike this guy is not gonna be happy
u bad
Ok, we got it
WHOOW
Ok, those apples can NOT be trusted
They're going to shoot VERTICALLY *shows up horizontally*
aah? aah? *genius*
That's right
Ok, you can't shoot the apples, but that's fine
mother fucker
*sorry censored content again*
Since when does apple kill anything
since when does apple will kill anything
Shut up appl es tuck ! What I say
Shut up apples duck what I say
Is anyone ever died from an apple?
A child died in 1921. The cause of her death was a stomach ache after eating green apples, so yes!
We need to trigger this apple. This game is about triggering apples
Look at the pure gaming skill, okay. Look. Oh, wow the apples. See? I'm one step ahead
Look at the pure gaming skill, okay. Look. Oh, wow the apples .see I'm one step ahead
I've thoght that they'll go vertically, but no they did not. (is pewdz related to science?)
Oh, god, that apple i don't trust for 1 second
great.
greeeeeaaaaaat
Just what I wanted !
Alright, let's take it easy
Take it easy. Let's take it easy. We can do this oh
*Creepy ''aaah''* aaaaaaaaaaaah
hah *boom*
Shut up you have to trigger all the apples then the to comet won't come
it's an old trick my
Grandpa told me all about it. Hey pewds. If there's ever a comet, trigger all the apples.
Grandpa told me all about it. Hey poods. If there's ever a comet, trigger all the apples I
I know were you thinking '' oh pewdipie giving up now''. You can't do it. I could do anything I want
Know were you thinking oh pewdiepie is giving up now. You can't do it. I could do anything. I want
*Long Censorship*
*swear words*
AAH you can't make that jump
Not today comet . ALRIGHT Fine coming you win this round.
Not today comet . ALRIGHT Fine coming you win this round.*High pitched voice* the game
*High pitched voice*
"ooh the game is hard, because you have to learn how the game works"
"I looked it up online"
"But that's fine because I'm good at game" come on comet. Come on comet come on comet
But that's fine because I'm good at deep come on comet. Come on coming come on come it
Don't you want to live forever?
*swearing*
*censored* comet
*swearing still*
Okay, so we got to trigger these two apples by jumping to them as close as humanly pahssible
Not today not today apples not today not any *swearing* day
because I am the apple Master of disaster. Oh comet. Oh comet
Oh, oh no, not that comet anything
It *censored* following you are you kidding me ?! What the hell
Not today, Mr. Apples. I'm Gonna Trigger this one too
I don't have time for you and your *swearing*
Oh my Lord, okay here it comes, Mr.Comet, please
My Lord, okay here it comes, Mr.Comet, please
OH NO !
No... NOOO !!
Nej (Swedish for No)
AAah
It's getting on
*Focused pewds*
Oh jesus
*Hardcore gaming activated*
I like that when u die :)
NNNNNNEEEEEEEEJJJJJJJ
*back to pewds's voice* AAAAH
SO CLOSE ! ZERO DEATH! *rip mic* Come on come on. Come on. Come on. Oh OH
SO CLOSE ! ZERO DEATH! Come on come on. Come on. Oh
Oh, this game is so hard. Oh, it keeps FOLLOWING ME. IT KEEPS FOLLOWING ME
This game is so hard. Oh, it keeps following me. It keeps following me WHYYY
*desesparated voice* WHYYYYYY
Why do u do this ? why ?? D:
-*incoherent mumbling*
AH,THAH
*censored content*. Just sit here. You can't touch me here you can't oh
*censored content* Just stay here ! You can't touch me  oh
aaah haha! haha!
*finally*
Bye, oh, oh *facepalms*
oh no !
You can't change the... ????
Leave me alone !
Leave me alone !!!
leave me alone
byeeee
byE
Okay, all right. Let's take it really nice and *censored content* easy I can shoot
Can I jump on link ?
Can I jump a link? I
I can't jump here. Okay? I'm safe here. Oh my God. Okay, okay. Let's go in this *swearing*
Save, shut up about your sword old man. Thank you
oh my god
aaah my Gah
Oh my god. Oh my, *japanese GAH* What is this game? That's so easy.Now i'm playing it
Oh my God*squeak*, what is this game? That's so easy now. I'm playing it
Gimme the swo-
*censored content*
The game called me a retard
You can't...
I'm ending this episode here, but this is not over
this is just the beginning, apples
*creepy laught*
You think you can beat me? The best *censored content* player in the world?
Leave a like, if you want part 2
squad Fam Jujitsu...
out